c'est en spectateur que richard virenque
et alex ou le vont désormais suivre la
deuxième partie du tour de france comme
lors cet autre coéquipier de chez
festina ils ont été contraints
d'abandonner après leur exclusion yards
par la direction du tour une image
restera dans nos mémoires le déchirement
et les larmes du plus médiatique des
coureurs français qui a vu d'un seul
coup son rêve s'envoler
stéphane zubar la journée de richard
virenque et des festina c'était d'abord
de la détermination
il me présentait sa rampe de lancement
que non pour ma part j'ai rien à voir
dans cette affaire
ok tout les flip partiront j'espère
quelques instants plus tard les mécanos
arrange les vélos plus question de
prendre le départ
pourtant à 13 heures changement de
programme les coureurs décident de
gagner la ligne d'arrivée
même s'ils savent qu'ils ne seront pas
chronométré ce n'est pas la peine de
prendre le départ ce n'est pas la peine
de chénier a checké qu'il n'ya pas ils
ne sont pas chronométrée et ne sont pas
tenus par le teneur et ne sont pas
suivies par un batteur alors comme
anonymes chez les routes de france
finalement les festina ne sont pas
partis la décision de les exclure a été
prise par la société du tour de france
très déçu richard virenque craque pour
de france et c'est la plus belle épreuve
au monde qui puisse exister donc comparé
pour que tous ces dirigeants nahdistes
qui sont là que pour cent ce moment l'un
puisse puisse partie rentrer chez eux
comme nous on va rentrer chez nous et
donc vive le tour de france 98 et je
remercie le public qui a été très très
qui nous a énormément soutenu et qui va
encore nous soutenir et je donne
rendez-vous et les prochaines demain le
tour partira sont les festina richard
virenque va rentrer chez lui dans le var
à 29 ans le quadruple meilleur grimpeur
du tour s'interroge peut-être sur son
avenir